a new poll claims that 0% of Iceland
errs under age 25 believe in the Bible
creation story and I have many questions
about the number 0% because the poll was
taken number 1 by an Icelandic polling
company for the Icelandic ethical
humanist association and they've
released zero information about the
methodology my instinct at that is that
if the number truly is 0% it's because a
very small number of people were polled
but let's not focus on 0% specifically
let's just assume it's a very low number
of Icelanders under 25 who believe in
the Bible creation story we've also
found that there is a major urban rural
split in Iceland on religious belief
which is increasingly something we're
noticing around the world if you are
rural you are way more likely to believe
the Bible creation story than if you are
urban which basically in Iceland means
you live in Reykjavik because that's
that's as far as I know the only real
City of any martha's is a small country
I think the entire population of the
countries like three or four hundred
thousand total so in any case big urban
rural split but what's clear is Iceland
is very secular and other than the
problems of trying to avoid inbreeding
because the population is so small and
the anti-semitism which has been a
problem for many years for Iceland they
seem to be doing fine with a smaller and
smaller amount of religion the biggest
the fastest growing religion in Iceland
is called zu ism zu is M not 0 and it's
an ancient Sumerian religion and kind of
considered more or less a protest group
so I questioned the exact numbers of
this poll but what what's very clear is
that in the developed world people are
moving away from religion more and more
quickly and that is going to be very
interesting over the next 10 15 25 and
even 50 years because I don't see
anything reversing this trend and we're
going to be in an increasingly religion
--less world over time it's an
interesting poll too because I wonder
about what you talked about like the
Bible creation story yeah if it has to
be literally interpreted or can it just
be figuratively interpreted like when it
says that God created the world in seven
days yet have to be seven 24-hour
Days periods I think it actually uh yeah
you're saying I don't think that one
matters because my sense is if you don't
believe God created the world in seven
days you probably don't believe that
even if each day is a thousand years
that God created the world in seven
thousand years you probably either
believe it or don't
I would guess but yeah there's probably
some people who are in-between who
depending on how they're interpreting
the question might answer differently I
think there's something to that but big
picture you also don't literally
interpret these poll results as no one
under 25 believes Bible creation no it
just seems like they didn't find anyone
yeah in the particular poll they just
didn't find anybody very interesting
I've only been to the Iceland Airport
I've never spent time there but I would
like to go there I think it would be a
super interesting place to go